my name is jonest uh I was born through
IVF adoption that was actually Frozen
for 7even years my biological parents
used IVF to have children of their own
and had 30 some extra embryos left over
after having four children of their own
wow uh being a Christian couple and with
the help of the Bush Administration Bush
administration's lawmaking they gave up
their fertilized embryos to uh for
adoption through a Christian
organization called snowflakes my
question is is the line drawn at
adoption of these IVF embryos or is it
drawn at the science in general uh the
the the bioethical question of what to
do about these uh Frozen embryos of
which you were one you are you're a
graduate of that stage of development uh
I think remains open that that one is so
profoundly uh novel that ethicists who
are far more advanced than I am uh
continue to debate that uh I think
stories such as yours are really the key
to opening up this entire debate because
you're living proof you're you're you're
a happy ending and living proof of the
evils of of IVF and surrogacy you were
locked in a freezer for seven years and
you're one of the rare lucky ones who
got out H how many of you are there not
very many not very many uh glad you're
with us beautiful testimony and I got to
bring you on the road with me uh you
know one can make a lot of logical
arguments but seeing living Pro is is a
lot more persuasive amazing I'm here to
ask a question about a c a particular
topic that I think is probably the most
important topic known to man um and that
topic is something that you disagree
with Matt Walsh on here we go yep and
I'm wondering what it would take for you
to change your mind on this important
topic of whether or not aliens exist
what would it take for Michael noes to
to agree with the light side of the
force and come to Luke Skywalker and
believe in the green Yodas of the
space of the space Lords that aliens
exist probably a traumatic brain
[Applause]
injury maybe a labotomy I don't know but
that would be it that that would be but
as as long as I have my faculties of
reason and I'm not lured into nonsense
by the libs or the demons uh then you Al
aliens are not real aliens come from
Guatemala they don't come from
Mars great question yeah
no yeah yeah thank you yeah yeah yeah
yeah I
mean is there a followup yeah yeah there
is a followup of course naturally yeah
you didn't think I came didn't come for
here for a followup yeah no I would I
would say uh what do you think about
Billy Graham um in his comments um about
believing that um that aliens could be
that if aliens do exist that they are um
in fact children of God they're God's
creation and that Jesus if you know if
they intelligent life out there um that
you know they're that God created them
as well I've heard a lot of different
theories especially from the Christian
Perspective I'm a Christian myself that
this wasn't entire wasn't entirely a
joke I was just kind of curious
perspective on all those arguments from
the Christian Perspective I really like
Billy Graham I think the guy did a lot
of good uh you know as a snapping papist
myself I uh have some theological
disagreements with Reverend Graham CS
Lewis made the same arguments he
suggested that it was possible that
extraterrestrial life could exist in
another world I am skeptical of it I
don't see why because the argument for
it that I usually here is that well it's
just statistics you know it's just
probability I mean the likelihood that
in this big vast universe that we're the
only life I mean come on the chances of
that are so slim
there is no basis for that claim
whatsoever because in order to know the
probability of Life existing on some
other planet you would need to know how
life begins in the first place and they
don't have any answer on they have no
idea what the origin of life is and I
think that the origin of life is
shrouded in mystery but I think I've got
a much better explanation of it than
they do certainly a more persuasive one
and so according to my understanding of
how life begins I think that uh God the
unmoved Mover The uncaused cause uh
creates all things and makes us after
his own image and so we sound kind of
special to me and when people come to me
and say what you think you're so special
you we're the only life on on the
Universe I would say yeah yeah I think
we're made in the image and likeness of
God so are then are if there were
intelligent life at least anywhere else
in the universe would that intelligent
life also be made in the image and
likeness of God I mean we are the only
intelligent life in as much as we're the
only beings that have a rational Soul we
have intellect and we have will that's
why we're the only beings that can be
put up on trial you you don't uh you
know arrest a gorilla for throwing a
banana at a person you know he doesn't
know what he's doing is uh it's just
Instinct they can't uh uh reason
abstractly so will the ET on the other
planet do that are they made in the
image and likeness of God do they look
like us I mean what would that even mean
for salvation history you're you're
saying that some have suggested well
they're they're unfallen creatures you
know um oh I I guess I I don't really
see how that's possible though because
the fall uh pervades the whole Cosmos
sin and then death pervade the cosmos as
John Milton beautifully illustrates
another Protestant who beautifully
illustrates in Paradise Lost so I I
don't I just I've never heard an
argument as to how that would work and
uh if if the argument is well people see
really shadowy weird things at night and
some say that you know they they've had
their minds read by dark shadowy beings
I'd say one they should probably go see
a shrink to make sure that their head is
screwed on straight and if the shrink
says they're smart they should probably
go see a priest because I'm I would be
much more convinced that those were
Spiritual Beings Than Physical beings
and when you say they're totally
unfallen or you know when you uh when
one might suggest that they're different
in in in a a way that would even deprive
them perhaps of a body well we have a
way of thinking about that already
that's Angels and Demons which people
have believed in all over the Earth for
all of human history and now the modern
Libs say that's crazy but but they
recognize that there are certain U
Unexplained Mysteries out there so then
the Liberals have to just invent demons
for Libs and that's basically what
aliens are do you think that there
exists any long-term secular or
political solution to the societal ills
we're facing as a country or is the only
real option a sort of spiritual
Revival well in in the long run you know
for all of our good a spiritual Revival
is of course necessary because I love
the Constitution as much as the next guy
but I don't make an idol out of the
Constitution it really is to to quote
anonin Scalia you know it's just a dead
piece of paper with words on it right
it's it's uh and and it's completely
meaningless it it it can't operate
unless people have virtue and believe in
it and want to want to follow it so uh
in the long run yes you need a spiritual
renewal but how do you get the spiritual
renewal many of my friends who are a
little more
libertarian a little more hands-off they
say well you know we've got to just keep
the government out of it whatever we
want to do but I I don't think that
makes any sense historically even within
the American historical tradition and
certainly doesn't make sense from the
perspective of politics and human nature
you know politics is just how we all
live together and get along and and we
are a social creature we're the
political animal so so we have a right
and inevitably we have this obligation
to establish norms and standards that's
what laws are and laws necessarily
entail morality and Ne morality
necessarily entails religion so anytime
anyone passes a law whether you're
talking about abortion or whether you're
talking about the speed limit you're
going to have moral arguments in some
some way or another and you're going to
enshrine some religious view or other
all of our founding fathers just about
agreed on this Thomas Jefferson in a
private letter once said we needed a
separation of church and state that was
the exception that proved the rule the
founding fathers were very clear you
needed a Christian morality uh that's
what John Adams said John Jay first
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court said
that he he was elated you know that he
celebrated that we had this shared
Christian Heritage that that allow us to
to have a society together so uh while
we all ought to pursue Holiness in our
own lives uh the political order is
going to enshrine some standards or
other and I would just assume those
standards be good true moral standards
rather than the heinous ugly ridiculous
false standards that exist today you
know we're going to be waving some kinds
of banners they can either be the
banners of the faith that formed our
civilization or they can be the rainbow
banners on the Portico of the white
house I'll take the former please